hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out a really fun new piece of
tech this is the insta 360 Evo you guys
may be familiar with the insta 360 1x
which has been one of my favorite
cameras this past year it did a full
review on the Institut 61 I do have
another one that I've been working on
for the insta 360 1x which is their
newest version a lot of you have seen
these types of videos that I have posted
on Twitter or Instagram you I've always
asked me which camera that is and this
is the camera that I use to do those and
what's great is I shoot although the
content directly here on the insta 361 X
and I connected to my phone and I do all
of the editing right in the palm of my
hand and then I post it it is absolutely
fascinating what is - Thor 61 has been
doing as far as 360s concerned because
they're making it easy and accessible
for basically anyone and now what they
have done with the insta 361 Evo
they have made a 360 camera and a 180
camera all in one I'll also be posting a
separate video that is all entirely shot
in 180 I don't know if any of you guys
have watched any one any content either
here on YouTube or in your headsets what
love at 180 is it is immersive but it's
not entirely taking you out of where you
are ok this 3d experience where you
actually feel like you're there so you
can just see just enough ahead of you to
the sides and up and down and you have
to worry about turning around or doing
anything super crazy or mobile so what i
do something that i do plan on exploring
more of and with the introduction of
this this is gonna make it super simple
there it is so essentially this is
creating a stereoscopic image so much
like you're seeing things with your two
eyes you're shooting that same type of
content but with two cameras side by
side as i had mentioned you can shoot
180 butts with a flip of the camera you
now instantly have a 360 camera since
revolutionary
a revolutionary in the sense of this is
something that anybody can buy this
isn't something
is insanely expensive that only
professionals can use this is something
that consumers are able to get let's see
what else is in the box oh this is this
is metal I got the cable here little
small bag so this will allow you to
shoot 5.7 k 360 video and photos so
let's get this thing hooked up to my
phone everything is super easy to
connect there it is it's already showed
up well that was it yes I want to join
this is actually magic happening right
now before your eyes hope that you're
here for the show
switch to the are 180 mode oh my gosh oh
my goodness
this is so cool so this is 180 as you
can see it goes to the edge to each edge
and what's great about in the 360 is
their software it's what I love so much
so we're gonna close this lock it and
now it instantly switched to 360 this
seamlessly synced together so my gosh
you can see the coffee cup I'm
disgusting and since there isn't a
screen on this you can use your phone as
the viewer you have all the controls
that you would need I'm gonna capture a
360 photo by pressing right here now I'm
gonna capture a 360 video I switched it
back over to video we're gonna hit that
so right now this is a clip that I
filmed on the 360 camera and as you can
see I'm going to pan around the room
okay now back over here so hi hello the
only problem about them 6006 see how
dirty my desk is what my favorite things
about the inside 360 software when I'm
using it on my phone and then I import
this footage is you can make it any sort
of size that you want
so I shoot a lot of things for Instagram
stories so I can make them vertical you
can make them a square you can make them
16 by 9 you can basically make them
anything
you
[Music]
now in 360 I'm in Boulder Colorado this
actually make your son's I've ever been
used it's cold
go figure there's snow on the ground but
there's a beautiful behind me there's
now
[Music]
it's source
frozen well having another time hat on
hold my pocket oh I have gloves this
whole time I had gloves what do you know
but you might be able to see what I'm
seeing on my phones I had a picture my
phone so going back to this app you can
actually put this into some of the VR
mode so in this mode if you put this
inside of like a VR headset you'll be
able to see what your camera is saying
and so we'll go back out of there scroll
around since this is in 180 still one of
the other things that I can't wait to
show you guys so this is a holographic
case they're coming with the naked eye
3d case so that's cool about this is
it's just a normal case you can wear it
wear it I mean I guess you technically
wear cases your phone does you couldn't
use it like a normal case but when you
want to watch a stereoscopic image in 3d
take this off the back of your case put
it on the front of your phone and then
this will be able to give you a 3d image
without wearing 3d glasses so you can't
really tell it all but you can see kind
of how it's giving my phone this effect
the first time that you use it it goes
through a little setup it analyzes your
face finds out where your eyes are and
it will make sure that everything is
perfectly aligned the first time that I
saw it you guys I was actually just I
almost hit the floor I wish I was
filming my reaction because it was
incredible my one tip for a lot of you
guys if you've never experienced or shot
with 180 before the key is to try to
keep it as still as possible because a
lot of times when you are watching these
things and headsets you want to
visualize the experience as if you were
sitting and watching something so you
don't want to have a lot of movement
because you want the movement to happen
from the person who's watching so if you
are walking or doing any of those types
of things
make it as steady as possible another
good practice that I notice is you
try to shoot from eye level so if you
are filming something try to keep it in
sort of the range that most people would
probably be standing so you don't want
to be too low because it'll look like
they are low to the ground if it's too
high then they'll look like they're
looking down on things unless that is a
perspective that you want so it really
is against an artistic choice but this
is such a new thing and I think a lot of
people are experimenting with it so if
you've seen any other cool 180 content
please please please tweet it to me
leave me a comment because I would love
to check it out
well I just want to give you guys a
quick little demo and an unboxing of
this because this was just announced by
insta 360 so I look forward to seeing
what people think of it also very
excited about going out and really
getting to test this thing leave me some
comments below let me know what you guys
think and I asked you a bunch of
questions throughout this video so also
feel free to answer those as well thanks
for watching I love you guys
[Music]